il vient tout juste d'être annoncée
c'est le readme neuf pros plus écrit en
grand regardez rémy neuf pros plus et ça
c'est chouette alors il ya le readme
neuf pros de plus près c'est dur à dire
remy neuf pros plus qui a été présentée
j'en ai deux autres également puis vous
en prêt très rapidement tout à l'heure
ils sont notés juste là c'est le readme
9 proba voyelles plus à leproux on s'en
doutera et puis elle me 9,6 mais nous
sommes montés à tout de suite c'est
celui là c'est le pro plus le plus grand
modèle et attendez je vais vous le dire
tout de suite se plurent un modèle il
coûte combien regarder on va se fait
noter et ça c'est vachement vachement
vachement intéressant parce que quand on
se parlera smartphones toujours situer
par rapport à son prix on a deux config
ici on va vraiment commencer tout de
suite par le prix pour savoir on a une
config 6 +128 giga de stockage et on a
également une config 8 + 2 156 giga de
stockage pour ce parricide un smartphone
milieu de gamme on est à
379 euros 99 et là on est à 4 129 euros
99 et alors je vous le dit puisqu'on y
tout de suite et qu'on veut se faire
plaisir les préco va toucher un peu
moins cher c'est du 23 au
27 février c'est ça en fait les 828 vous
touchez pas à 370,9 vous l'avez à
349 euros 99 hockey et le 8 256 vous
l'avez pas à 4 129 99 vous l'avez à
399 euros 99 c'est à dire un peu moins
de 400 euros un petit peu moins pas
beaucoup moins mais quand même un petit
peu moins donc c'est quand même pas mal
ça c'est des offres limitées du 23 au 25
février s'il vous intéresse je vous mets
le lien bien évidemment juste embarque
dans la description pour le situons nous
entourent 350 euros 400 430 euros pour
ce smartphone là en fonction de la
configuration que vous souhaiterez avoir
donc voilà comme ça on va pouvoir
réellement savoir comment situez vous
allez voir je n'ai pas ouvert je voulais
voir avec vous on nous annonce des trucs
assez dingue assez spectaculaire au
niveau du dos il changerait de couleur
on va regarder ça remy m'a demandé de
venir le tester c'est donc aujourd'hui
une vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec remy pour venir découvrir ce
nouveau rythme y neuf pros plus je vous
cache pas que j'ai hâte on y va
c'est toujours un moment un peu
religieux le boxing en smartphones on a
hâte de découvrir
ces désirez suivre ok alors là on
commence vraiment sur un truc un peu ce
temps là on connaît effectivement les
petites bottes jaunes d'oeufs réduit et
welcome to hear me famery merci réduit
l'aide en bresse et new john est ok on y
va je le fais l'accent qu'il va bien
comme ça je fais vraiment voyager alors
ton et qu'est ce que je vais avoir ça
souffle sur le dessus j'ai quoi à
l'intérieur j'ai à une petite coque
regardez on vous devine déjà le module
photo petite coque transparente hockey
de corps vraiment tiroirs de cartes sim
et puis une petit dock j'imagine ça va
être les garanties tout si tout ça tout
ça ok ça c'est bien on se le met de côté
ensuite le smartphone en lui-même
regarder les mariés par là il est par là
il est par s'il est par là on se le
garde dans quelques instants ce qu'un
petit peu de suspense ensuite on a quoi
eh bien on a du globe de chambre alors
regardez ça c'est pas du bloc de charge
qui est fait pour se marrer c'est de la
super dakhla super d'arte c'est quoi
c'est la recharge très rapide ici c'est
un bloc de charge de 60 watts est-ce
qu'il vous l'ont écrit quelque part
absolument passer écrit nulle part donc
là c'est de la recharge rapide 60 watts
pour venir recharger extrêmement
rapidement on va avoir un petit câble en
plus ici en usb à verre de l'usbc c'est
la recharge usb c'est pas d'écouteurs
aujourd'hui la loi française n'oblige
plus avoir des écouteurs à l'intérieur
mais c'est quand même bien ici rémy vous
avez un blog de charge rapide 60 watts
pour c'est vraiment à venir utiliser
lubbock de charge de rien pas utiliser
deux blocs de georges parce qu'il n'ya
pas de compatibilité donc si vous voulez
profiter de recharge 60 watts et le bloc
de charges ici super d'arte et pas un
autre alors on continue on va regarder
vraiment ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur parce
que c'est vraiment le truc qui
m'intéresse le dos là j'ai trop hâte
j'aime bien le dos c'est super joli le
module photo aussi c'est pareil est
vraiment très très très très très très
très joli on se retrouve avec un triple
capteur photo on se regarde la config
tout à l'heure là je me donnerais pas ce
que vous allez voir ça intéresse allez
j'ose pas eu un peu le truc qu'on a un
capteur principal de 50 méga pixels mais
sans leur en gardant quelques instants
et puis voici regarde également les
photos je vais faire un tour comme ça on
va faire cette vidéo en deux temps tu
aimes bien il ya un espèce de reflets
que vous voyez là qui est très jolie les
reflets se baladent légèrement c'est
très sympa hein c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment jolie elle retrouve le brendan
green mis sur le côté ça une fois de
plus un grand classique dans la marne
donc c'est vrai que c'est très sympa
super jolie smartphone on a et ça c'est
pas mal c'est plutôt rare une prix jack
sur le dessous pour venir brancher un
casque filaire en jack si on le souhaite
de la recharge en usb c'est ok on s'en
doutera des haut parleurs stéréo le
petit bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre quai situé là sur le dessus
le petit micro pour la réduction de
bruit ici je vais retrouver votre tiroir
de khartoum avec une double dano sim 5
j'ai donc si vous avez besoin de deux
cartes sim saint-gilles vous pouvez les
avoir et puis vous avez en plus ici de
quoi monter et baisser le volume donc on
va seul ouvrir on va le regarder ça
c'est vraiment très sympa déjà la config
de base je trouve assez joli riehl mais
il va s'ouvrir alors ici voilà la bête
alors regardez là toujours notre dos à
tour notre phase là j'avais allumé donc
là capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
déverrouille rapidement donc ça c'est
plutôt bien qu'est ce qu'on voit ici et
bien on voit qu'on a un bel écran et ça
c'est chouette ont un écran ici on est
sur du super amoled super amoled oui
mais pas que regarder on vient ici dans
les paramètres on vient d'en affichage
et luminosité fréquence d'actualisation
de l'écran regarder se situer c'est
marqué juste ici fréquence
d'actualisation de l'écran alors là vous
avez une sélection automatique soit vous
êtes surélevé vous êtes tout le temps et
en 90' c'est parce qu'ici on a un taux
de rafraîchissement 90's adaptative là
il est marqué en sélectionne
automatiquement ça veut dire que cette
adaptatif lorsque vous n'avez pas besoin
de taux d'imposition de 90 heures vous
n'êtes pas en 90 ans mais lorsque vous
en avez besoin et bien paf vous arrivez
sur 90 ans si maintenant vous voulez
pousser pour rester tout le temps sur le
90e vous appuyez ici surélevée et
l'absurde eu 90 ans permanent l
intention de laisser en 90 ans tout le
temps ça va venir consommer un peu plus
au niveau de votre batterie donc je vous
conseille de laisser en automatique ou
sinon vous restez en standard vous serez
en 60 hertz et qu'on va retrouver
usuellement sur un smartphone le mieux
ceci étant dit entre vous et moi c'est
de rester ici en sélectionner
automatiquement comme sarah switcher
entre du 60 et 90 hertz ça c'est cool
alors après on a plein de petites
fonctionnalités au niveau logiciel le
confort des yeux qu'on peut venir
activer désactiver le moteur 0 1 0 1 0 1
point que c'est 0-1 ultra vision qu'on
va pouvoir venir exactement ici activé
pour venir améliorer l'image grâce à
deux lits a donc ça c'est pareil ces
logiciels et senna chemin parce que ici
au tourne sur read me why 3.0 donc on a
pas mal de petites fonctionnalités qui
sont très très cool luminosité
automatique ou pas le mode sombre si
vous souhaitez avoir un mode sombre ou
pas ça c'est bien parce que ça permet
d'économiser de l'énergie pourquoi parce
que vous êtes sur un écran une fois de
plus super amoled donc c'est de l'oled
donc tous les pixels noirs vont des
pixels et un donc en vous mettant en
mode sont vous allez contribuer à
économiser de la batterie alors la
batterie normalement vous est peinard
vous avez une batterie de 4500 millions
par ici c'est quand même très grand et
en plus de ça vous avez de la recharge
60 watts à je voulais dire c'est la
super d'art charge donc ça va vite c'est
rassurant c'est bien donc là dessus pas
de soucis qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver
également au niveau software et bien
alors bon wifi bluetooth ok ça on s'en
doute on peut me dire personnaliser un
petit peu le truc les fonds d'écran les
icônes les animations d'empreintes
digitales expérience est assez complète
un plutôt bien fichu ici sécurité
confidentialité société spéciale
bien-être numérique contrôle parentaux
bon un très très grand classique
convient retrouver ici regardez ici vous
le montrer ça c'est plutôt intéressant
on le voit que le processeur c'est un
médiathèque saint dit man city 920 alors
pour ceux qui ne sauraient pas le 10 mai
le sit-in 920 c'est un processeur qui
est gravé en 6 nanomètres qui vous
apportera de la performance qui vous
permettra aussi d'avoir de la fluidité
notamment avec vos 8 gigas de ram ici
pour venir jouer à différents jeux ici
et ça donc pour le gaming on a aussi ce
qu'il faut c'est intéressant alors ce
qu'on vient voir regarder j'en reviens
petit peu ici on voit qu'on a
effectivement à plat un petit menton sur
le bas mais qu dans cette gamme de prix
me dérange absolument pas cette petite
caméra qui est poinçonnet ici à l'avant
et on se regarde aussi une fois de plus
dans quelques instants on a également
des haut parleurs stéréo haut parleurs
stéréo ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on est
effectivement un petit haut parleur de
renforts et six sur le côté mais
globalement ce avant la qualité vraiment
connaître
ça va
celui là il maintient
le son est très bien on a pas sont
criards là je voulais tout c'est un
front
ça sature pas particulièrement
ça c'est assez équilibré pour moi qu'on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
c'est vraiment bien dans l'expérience là
dessus aussi elle est plutôt cool on est
en plus ici compatible dolby atmo si
vous venez brancher vos écouteurs donc
ça c'est plutôt cool alors il a une
fonctionnalité qui est intéressante mais
que je n'ai pas ici il faudrait le voir
effectivement sur le modèle bleu il a un
style qu'on va appeler un style caméléon
et dire qu'il a un design
photochromiques alors sous le nom un peu
barbare du style caméléon du design
photochromiques ce qu'en fait si vous
prenez le modèle bleu est bien en
mettant soleil il va passer dans le
rouge ça c'est plutôt rigolo alors il
existe plusieurs couleurs moi j'ai les
modèles noirs ici il existe en vert
aurore en bleu ciel et puis bon voilà la
couleur la plus sobre je pense se nouera
des reflets noir un peu soyons vraiment
côté très soyeux dans ses reflets ça
c'est plutôt sympa au truc qui est
intéressant à savoir dans ce smartphone
c'est que vous avez 8 g la phase 6 ou 8
gigas de ram moi j'ai une version 1 8
gigas de ram ici et vous pouvez aller en
réalité jusqu'à 13 giga de ram avec de
la ram dynamique qu'est ce que ça fait
c'est très dynamique en fait ça vient
puiser dans leurs hommes le rhum c'est
le stockage cd puiser dans le stockage
et ça vous transforme une partie de vos
stockage en ram dynamique pour venir
apporter un gain de fluidité à portée de
la performance en ce que vous allez
venir l'utilisé notamment lorsque vous
allez jouer alors ici nous ont installé
un petit à petit j nativement donc si
vous venez jouer apple j ai bien vous
allez venir récupérer que c'est très
dynamique pour vous apporter de la
fluidité donc ça c'est chouette alors
regardez le truc qui nous intéresse
beaucoup ici c'est la partie photo vidéo
parce que c'est vraiment une partie qui
est très très très mise en avant et qui
va vraiment nous intéressait parce qu'on
utilise tous nos smartphones pour faire
de la photo de la vidéo alors vous voyez
vous avez trois capteurs ok alors les
qu'est ce que ça raconte le premier que
vous avez ans c'est un capteur de 50
méga pixels c'est la sony mx 766 qui a
une stabilisation optique donc ça c'est
plutôt intéressant alors ya plusieurs
modes photo on a quoi le street mode le
filtre années 90 on a le smart longue
exposent leurs pour la photo de nuit on
a le pick and go bref on va aller faire
quelques petits plans avec et je vous
montrais ça vous avez ensuite en ultra
grand angle de 8 mégapixels qui
situaient puis on le voit porté sur le
côté c'est de la macro et à l'avant vous
avez une caméra de celle fille qui est
juste là c'est une 16 mégapixels alors
regardez ce que vous montrez on est dans
le software ya pas mal de petites choses
vachement intéressante alors vous pouvez
venir pousser déjà vos photos en 50 méga
pixels si vous le voulez parce que sinon
ça va venir utiliser plusieurs pixels on
va regrouper en les mettre en installer
m'appliquerai pour ressortir des photos
que nombre de mégapixels qui sera
moindre mais on gagnera en luminosité
voilà des atouts qui est très rigolo
donc là vous le voyez fois un on peut
venir nous mais numériquement convient
résumé dans le 50 méga pixels on n'a pas
de tels objectifs donc c'est du
numérique on a notre ultra-grand-angle
ok vous avez un mode vidéo donc jusque
là tout va bien on peut venir filmer
regardez vos liées aux vidéos jusqu'en
4,4 en fps sinon on fera le 1080p en 60
ou 30 fps ok et puis surtout ce qui est
vachement rigolo lorsque vous allez dans
le mode rue la dôle mode rue vous avez
les équivalents mm donc là vous voyez
que en fait votre foi c'est un 24 mm
vous voyez que votre foi 2 et bien 150
mm et vous voyez que votre
ultra-grand-angle c1 16 mm c'est très
très très très logique donc on va
l'essayer ce mode rue je trouve assez
rigolo donc on a quoi ici jpeg parce que
je vois la ville rose ils payent donc je
peux vous dire je souhaitais henrot
aussi ah ouais ça c'est assez marrant
aussi au caire est chouette pour pouvoir
venir travailler ensuite dans lightroom
si on le souhaite g1 nuit mon maître
vidéos photos en mode portrait également
et puis je vois que j'ai de l'ultra
macro qui est là je vois rien on va se
positionner là ultra macro alors j'ai
une peau une peau sèche linge un peu une
peau de crocodile en ce moment à cause
de la sortie de l'hiver mais on peut
venir se rapprocher faire des trucs donc
on va aller faire quelques petites
photos et puis on va regarder ce que ça
raconte si c'est bien ou pas je vous
montre les photos prises par le readme 9
propulsa le regard des deux plein jour
ça fonctionnera c'est pas mal on a une
très bonne gestion des contrastes le
ciel est bien on voit que derrière et
bien on n'a rien de cramer pour autant
alors là on a un style très fort donc
bon mais c'est plutôt pas mal on va
continuer passé sur l'ultra grand-angle
alors bon on s'en doute reiss il n'y a
pas de magie on va venir perdre un petit
peu que ça être un peu moins précis
moins parfaits moins bon mais c'est
normal c'est un ultra grand angle sur
smartphone qui vient se situer entre
379 à 429 euros donc bon à rien de bien
surprenantes on peut venir nous met un
peu si on le souhaite un peu pas trop
parce que si vous au métro et bah c'est
moins beau mais c'est normal donc à rien
de surprenant ici et on s'y résout
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
non non mais c'est normal j'ai essayé
différentes choses avec différentes
expos pour venir voir si ça fonctionne
et sur votre capteur principal atout que
le rendu est vraiment correct on a bien
les voitures qui vient de ressortir on a
bien aussi brillé sur zone un peu plus
exposés si ça fonctionnera le soleil qui
arrive qui tape de l'autre côté ici sur
l'opéra bastille et bien ça marche donc
je trouve que dans l'idée ça fonctionne
pas mal une fois de plus même remarque
sur you tra grand temps où on vient
perdre en terme de précision mais ce
n'est pas anormal donc un réel
surprenant ici ça vous permet quand même
de venir shooter des bâtiments un peu
plus large donc ça fera son job ou à
venir vous menez un peu hockey trop non
il ya un truc qui est aussi assez
intéressant c'est qu'en fait ici il ya
un vrai travail on y voit le go
rythmique sur cette photo lâche pas si
vous en rendrez bien compte c'est que là
en haut on est jeune qui est mieux
exposé qu'un petit contre jour derrière
et là c'est beaucoup plus sombre dans le
bas donc est ce que fait votre votre il
ya derrière et bien il vient compenser
alors il ya forcément un côté qui va
être un peu plus plat sur les façades
ici sur la compensation sur un
smartphone dans ce segment de prix mais
ça me paraît normal donc ici ça ne
surprend pas des masses néanmoins les
bateaux on les voit bien ils sont mieux
exposés donc il ya vraiment cette photo
qui assemblés entre un côté qui est très
exposé un peu moins et pas trop pour
nous sortir au final une photo cohérente
et qui fonctionnera globalement sur
l'ultra grand temps qu'on le voit il a
un petit peu plus demain mais ça c'est
aussi un peu normal dans cette dans
cette gamme de smartphones et à ce
moment après venise ou mai mais là il a
du mal à compenser davantage on le voit
au niveau du ciel qui va être un peu
moins bien les façades un poil plus
lissée mais voilà on va pas non plus
attendre attendre qu'il fasse des
miracles j'ai fait un peu de maquereaux
l'histoire de regarder puisque on peut
faire de la macro bon c'est vraiment
extra de faire de la macro je suis pas
de toute façon fans de ces modes de
macro avec des caméra de 2 mégapixels on
sort pas des choses extraordinaires mais
si vous voulez de la macro vous pouvez
voir la macro caméra de celle fille non
plus je ne suis pas extrêmement fans ça
fera le job on sortira des photos qui
seront cohérentes mais en termes de
teintes de peau et de grain de peau je
trouve pas ça très joli sud poteau je
vous ai prises avec un mode qui est un
peu particulière qui s'appelle le mode
rue où le sweat mode en fait c'est vous
prenez votre smartphone pec vous voyez
un truc que vous appuyez ça déclenche
directement c'est une espèce de
déclenchement rapide ça fonctionne rien
de rien de surprenant là dessus et après
il existe également un mode nuit où vous
allez pouvoir venir sortir des photos
alors moi j'ai pas de trépied donc pour
vous faire des photos en longue
exposition c'est un peu plus compliqué
la relation des expos je crois de 2,4
secondes mais moi vu que je bouge je
tremble eu des mains je suis pas
forcément le bon client pour ça non peut
on peut venir faire des choses mais pour
autant s un smartphone sans laquelle il
faut venir faire de la photo de nuit je
ne suis pas convaincu ça c'est un mode
portrait dans l'ensemble des tours
plutôt pas trop mal fait pas trop mal le
taf il va avoir un peu plus de mal ici
parce qu'on vient complexifier les
scènes voyez entre les doigts mais je
dirais que ça reste globalement du point
de détail alors après vous êtes d'autres
qui sont assez marrant vrai plein de
filtres différents voyez vous permettent
de venir vous amuser alors ils vous
appellent ça faisait des filtres années
90 donc on a plein de filtres un peu
différent cyberpunk ça c'est quoi ça
c'est de l'or donc voilà donc si vous
voulez faire un truc un peu créatif avec
plein de titres eh bien vous avez plein
de filtres de tous les côtés que vous
allez retrouver directement dans votre
partie photos mais également
dans la partie vidéo voyez si je veux
dire faire un truc comme ça on çà et
carla je peux venir le faire si je veux
mettre en avant alors attendez c'est
quoi ça du noir et blanc là comme ça
voilà il ya plein de mode assez marrant
que vous pouvez venir retrouver ici sur
notre riz le mil neuf pros plus pour
permettre d'exprimer l'intégralité de
notre créativité et ça c'est marrant
alors il ya également d'autres
smartphones qui sont disponibles ont été
présentés alors moi je vous présente le
plus beau le plus grand le plus sympa
c'est le readme neuf pros plus mais vous
avez également le rémi neuf pros alors
il ya quelques différences il a
également effectivement ce style
caméléon grâce à son design
photochromiques on aura un capteur
principal au niveau des photos de 64
mégapixels avec différents modes
l'industrie tmmob 990 pareil on aura les
mêmes modes on a ici par contre pas un
écran super amoled on est ici sur du lcd
adaptatif avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va de 30 f jusqu'à
120 le processeur on est chez qualcomm
avec l'ancien dragon
695,5 j'ai une grosse batterie de 5000
milliampères heures une charge rapide 33
watts et on tourne également sur risle
be why 3.0 mon appareil à la rame
dynamique jusqu'à 13 giga de ram le
capteur d'empreintes digitales cette
fois ci sera sur la tranche une caméra
frontale de 16 mégapixels et puis on un
stockage jusqu'à 128 il n'y a pas de
haut parleurs stéréo à six haut parleurs
monoprix vous avez de config sur leurs
ennemis neuf pros je donne les tarifs du
rémi neuf pros vous avez deux versions
628 giga de stockage à 319 euros 99 que
vous pouvez avoir du 23 au 27 février à
299 euros 99 puis une version 828 giga
de stockage à 349 euros 99 que vous
pouvez avoir toujours pareil du 23 au 27
à 3 129 99 qui vous avez également le
rytme 9 et où là on a un écran full hd
90's caméra de celle-ci de 16 mégapixels
en un triptyque l arrière 50 méga pixels
2 mégapixels 2 mégapixels le stand
dragonne 680 on a une batterie de 5000
méliand père lors de la recharge rapide
30 3 watts une rame dynamique on palais
jusqu'à 11 ea a drame des haut parleurs
stéréo et un stockage jusqu'à 128 go de
stockage le capteur d'empreinte digitale
est situé sur la tranche on tourne ici
sourit mireille 2.0 elle en rit 2009 si
vous avez deux config 4 + 64 à 219 99
vous pouvez avoir à 199 199 donc en
dessous des 200 euros donc ça c'est
vachement bien une version 428 giga de
stockage à 239 euros 99 que vous pouvez
toucher également
23 au 27 février à 219 euros 99 bien
évidemment je vous mets tous les liens
en bas de la description pour aller voir
ses smartphones de les trouver au
meilleur prix j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aurez intéressés à découvrir ce
smartphone en tout cas que je trouve
mois plus tôt c'est sympa on les situer
sur du milieu de gamme et un design qui
est sympa en termes de photos sur 50
méga pixels on sort de choses qui sont
plutôt chouette on fait des photos
chouette sur le 50 méga pixels et si
vous êtes un gamer que vous voulez jouer
voulais juste de la fluidité avec votre
dit man city 920 5 g vous avez ce qu'il
faut a vous de me dire vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas de ce smartphone
comment vous le trouvez ce rytme neuf
pros plus vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaires dont on se retrouve très
vite pour monter des mails évidemment
parler de smartphones par les d'actu
parler de ri il me parlait plein de
choses donc ça c'est chouette nous
embrasse pour les soins de vous à
bientôt jazz
[Musique]